these first two drills are just by
yourself
okay
and as we said you have to take fear off
the table
and
people that are
amidst chaos and fear other people scare
them
the second you introduce someone
you're already triggering them okay
so these first two drills are by
yourself
okay
so the first drill is you can see how
you're
decreasing
everything
all the triggering aspects for somebody
you're going to lay down
on the mat
and you're going to do corpse pose but
not be in corpse pose
you're more open
and release
and the first variant of this drill is
to do it sharply and over exaggerating
an activation
attention in the center
do not
activate your arms or your legs
your center
that is currently releasing and relaxing
and dropping
will percussively
flex
and release
and you will let it go all the tension
it's in there
and when it's gone
and release
at the beginning you'll hold your breath
that's fine
your change will be longer that's fine
it's all fine what's not fine is this
this is me moving my head legs and
hands i don't want that i don't want
consciousness in them
i want my
effort my intention in here
okay let's try it
so you're consciously moving your head
your head is relaxed
but you see it's stuck
do you see that
that's your legs
so your feet are right now not connected
to your center
that that's a conscious movement of your
upper shoulders and neck area which is
why it moved
don't you don't move your extremities
now
the next drill
is
taking you more and more
into the religious overlay so
i do have to have this
relationship
so that i generate order
here represented by the extremities to
my center
but ultimately there's going to be a
center
to my relationship with okay
in other words there's going to be order
and there's going to be order to how i
fall
and all of those things are
cultivation arenas by which
i either succumb to
the fear or i stay
in the iq okay so we're going to start
generating um
the spiraling
aspect
to this center periphery
organization
so i'm going to open my feet up
and i still right now i establish i'm
going to establish the order okay and
i'll first do
disorder
so when i'm sitting like this
okay see my upper body is not related to
my feet
i'm going to use that percussive moment
of flexion of the last drill
to
prolong
the order here
not like this this disconnected
order
and i'm going to pay attention to the
relationship between my head and feet
so i'm going like this my feet
don't move my head is moving as as my
head moves my feet will get
will be moving because i'm keeping that
order
i'm not picking up my lens
i'm locking it and my head is moving and
i'm keeping that order
okay we're going to go around in the
circle
and this is also going to give the new
student
the
hand foot coordination
of the later break falls okay
so as my head goes down
and to my right the left leg is going to
stay in that relationship
so left head leg head and right hand
okay
so disorganized would be like this
organizes it goes together
and i'm using this to get up and to go
down to get up and to go down
so we'll do one way i'm going around
boom the pattern is hand hand foot foot
hand hand foot foot
you go and then you want to go the other
way hand hand foot foot
your head stays in that relationship
with your feet in this relationship
so you see where my head is
stays there
keep your feet apart
don't let them come in
okay let's try that
so right there you you felt that little
right there do you feel that yes okay so
that looks like strength to me
okay so we we have to condition to get
rid of that
there's no point in asking you
spiritually to remain ordered if
physically you cannot okay
but there's not really that much
strength in this drill
in terms of picking up your head
why
you can use your you can counter
yeah you're counter weighting okay so
really what's happening before you
have that strength requirement is you
disconnected okay so try it again
use your leg to pick up your head
[Music]
separate your feet
so it's foot hand hand foot foot not
hand hand feet
all right
separate your feet
change direction
do you see your breath getting
compromised
okay
i can do it like this
that's not it okay
um my extremities
again have the same kind of unconscious
but uh you know flexion
but my center has the percussive flexion
now pull along so don't as you're
working it get rid of the of the tension
in your body
now
[Applause]
it is not necessary nor practically okay
try it again
there's a lot of break and you first go
down
right there
right there broken do you see your foot
didn't move
fading your back
breathe
straighten your back
let's see the breaking break break break
okay so now i'm going to take that
organization
and kill a couple birds with one's
stone so the first one i'm going to use
is uh cesa it says not
disconnect like this okay
cesar is already
that organization
in play
you're already learning and doing and
practicing
the very body organization that you're
using in your nagewasa and of course in
your campaign
so you're already in that relationship
so we're going to now extend that
relationship and take one component of
the last drill and i'm going to relate
and generate that order by relating my
head to my foot so i'm going to take my
head left foot right hand okay
and do one portion and start to learn
this back break fall okay but it's key
that i'm not disconnecting not over
tension
everything is just my body
and i'm going to experience
a slight feeling of falling and this is
where that fear comes in and the
disorganization comes in okay but you
were already falling in the last row so
use your imagination to make this drill
like the last row
we're going to do back breakfall
uh mechanics starting with the right
side okay so as my body comes out my
head is moving my leg will come out
and this would be if i continue the last
drill
incorrect would be this
you can see i'm segmented
so from cesa
sliding out
lock tension won't out
my eyes will remain forward and i will
end with my head off the mat and my feet
up
out
i get up i'm reversing that organization
when i get up
i'm using it
to get up
from there you can
uh introduce the timing aspects of
hitting the mat so i'll do the same
thing out
hands back in
[Music]
okay let's try that
do both sides
okay in the first drill we had an on off
aspect to our center and the second
drill i kept it on in this last drill i
keep it on and we're going to keep it on
um
for a while because that's the best way
of teaching someone but what we're going
to do is start seeking height you seek
height
fear comes in
you're going to lose the order
and you're not doing you can be okay
so from cesar
i'm going to go to kiza
but hon me again this is the front
i now teaching the back leg which is
what we use to step into this spiraling
geometry that's going to be used to
throw me okay
so
both these are on the mat i'm on the
balls of my feet
the right leg marks the direction that
i'm going to uh be projected on a spiral
and it also marks the inside hand which
we used to hit if we have it but i'm
going to do the same head and leg
relationship as i'm going out i keep my
eyes forward out
use the same exercise to get up
reset the drill so the beginner feels
knees down feet it might for some it
starts to freak them out but obviously
they're still touching the mat okay i do
the same drill head starts to go leg
comes out
[Music]
okay let's try that one most of us
okay next drill you take one leg up one
leg up and it's the same drop
one leg up
and this leg is lowering the head
so i'm not falling and picking the leg
up there's doing both
yes the legs coming up because the
head's going down but the leg is helping
to lower the head through the organized
center
okay let's try it mostly
okay uh this one both knees are up
i have that same box center
goes down the same way
[Music]
some errors come in because the momentum
is going to increase
and uh these are not martial
and again
it's singularity it's division-based
this disorder is disconnect
so you're gonna go you'll see the extra
momentum
and you'll give your back
don't give your back as you get
same cesa upper body posture
still oriented this way
still in this l-shape to the line of
attack okay let's try both sides
okay so what you've done pedagogically
is you've taken the second drill
and you've just used it
to try to reconcile fear in the student
as they're going along okay
uh
now we're going to start standing but i
have my feet in keys of the last row
right now some people start freaking out
so you go no no it's like the last drill
you just go down
and do it
boom open your knees drop center lock
usually at this point you'll see the
beginner mistake but you'll see that a
lot of schools will
make this
maybe intentionally even
because as they go down
this leg's going to roll in
and this is now going to keep their head
on the line of attack
that doesn't work run
because the back right ball kazushi
is on this spiral here
it's not on this one
oh i'm doing it
he's going this way
and as i said
there's a lot a larger order there's the
order between his body periphery center
then the order between he and i and the
order between he and i the attack and
the throne okay so you can't just fall
in the old way you have to
maintain this organization alright so as
i'm doing this drill
i open and i do the last drill the knee
goes this way
okay let's try both sides
so pedagogically i'm only uh i'm only
inserting the illusion of height because
it drops down to the same other level
but it is enough to start generating
fear in the intestine now i'm going to
enter
introduce the illusion of momentum okay
so i'm going to have them start with the
right foot forward
take one step back into the last row go
down
and do the same last row
so it's one step
one step
down
again don't let the momentum expose your
block
that's a no-no you're losing connection
with the noggin
okay
try it both sides
okay now you're going to increase
the age the illusion of momentum and
you're going to reintroduce agency okay
so they have to take the dashi has to
take at least
three steps
and then they can decide
where they're going to go
down which foot
okay
when they walk they walk straight back
not in an artificial way
just straight back
and when they decide to take the fall
that's when that foot goes into the last
drill
okay
so you're walking
i decide down
walking
down foot out
when they feel comfortable you can have
them pick it up
okay try both of those at your face
most of us find uh
a lot of comfort in our
controlling of the situation
so we that but that is not in kim
the comfort is not a chemi
the control is not a chemi
nor the fear that it's operating through
or because of
so
uh what he's gonna do now
is push me
with some energy
[Music]
you remember these days
okay so he's gonna push me i'm gonna
absorb that energy
in the number of steps
that i end up taking
and i when i go to the fall
i turn the foot out and i do that other
drill so he's pushing
don't let the extra momentum
turn you around
at this point
we can teach how to get up
we use a triangle get up
so
a little slower he's pushing
i'm going down
and it's just a standard jiu-jitsu
triangle get up come up with your body
post the hand cross bottom hand and foot
step out
up
the end slope
don't use the energy
okay give you a block and come around
that's a no-no
push
okay let's try comparison
okay since i lose my agency to a degree
and the guy has control this is really
where you start to see the
disorganization come in because the fear
sets in the darkness sets in and it it's
chaos it disorganizes things so i
started to have my center
moving with all my extremities moving
okay
so
uh the other thing that we've done up
till now is we used a static hold to
generate strength and coordination but
that's not really marginally functional
the first drill where you have a
percussive flexion that is what we're
after so we have to get back now to that
if you look that kind of happened here
because
people are like loose and then you have
to find your center so without them
knowing it
they're already getting a kind of
percussion but oftentimes their solution
is instead to do it with a disconnect
you see
instead of with
the
foot head coordination and that does not
work because when he disconnects his
head is coming forward and if i was
throwing him backwards his head is going
backwards so if he came forward i would
be adding force at impact to let's say a
palm heel strike or something okay so
his head has to keep going backwards my
head goes always this way
i can't have my head go here
with that percussion with that flexion
my head is going
back up
so on this drill
we're going to go
and hit that percussion
from the opposite extreme
because we don't want it we don't want
the head coming forward
so he's going to hold my
hakama
and get me to extend my center the other
way
the identity can decide what they're
comfortable with
but the goal is to let it go let it go
as far as possible so come up off your
heels
you don't have your legs like this
you're just normal
he's holding me i don't have control he
decides
when he's going to let go
that's when i percuss the center like
the first drill okay so he's holding me
i give him my weight
and i go into the fall
i get up
with the triangle get up
so here
i'm not
so vertical like in all the other drills
i have a bow
that i'm going to flex like the very
first drill we did
and i'll find my foot
okay let's try
it a little bit more flexion a little
earlier
more
double it
bring your head and limbs all forward
like the first drill
a little better
okay so you have all that control you're
still in control
that's a big response
let yourself hang in their hands
you see it's a little harder now right
you got to flex more like the first one
give your give your body entirely to
them
entirely to them
expose your throat expose your throat
let yourself come back
okay so i i don't
it's very subtle but do you feel it
do you feel your fear
okay so you gotta get rid of that you
gotta open your throat more like a human
sacrifice expose your belly expose your
throat
accept as you stop stop stop
uh taylor take priscilla's spot
expose
your throat
there
okay everybody see how you see how she
tried to regain that did you see that
okay and that's not ukemi
okay